una acción inmediata y ambiciosa para
prohibir productos químicos tóxicos
esto pidiera uno en un informe
medioambiental donde advierte que las
muertes por la polución son mayores a
las producidas por la pandemia la
contaminación está matando a más
personas cada año que las que la
pandemia de kobe 19 ha matado en el
transcurso de los últimos dos años y sin
embargo no recibe ni de lejos la
atención del público o de los
responsables políticos la contaminación
por plaguicidas plásticos y residuos
electrónicos causa más de 9 millones de
muertes al año el documento insta a que
se limpien los lugares contaminados y
sean reubicadas en casos extremos las
comunidades afectadas pobres indígenas o
marginadas que viven en las llamadas
zonas de sacrificio este término
utilizado originalmente para describir
las zonas de pruebas nucleares se amplió
en el informe para incluir cualquier
sitio muy contaminado o inhabitable por
el cambio climático lista estas zonas de
sacrificios se encuentran no sólo en los
países pobres sino que se encuentran en
los países ricos
mientras la administración nacional
oceánica y atmosférica de eeuu noaa
lanza otra advertencia el nivel del mar
podría subir en este país de 25 a 30
centímetros en promedio para 2050
una de las afirmaciones más profundas de
este informe es que se espera que eeuu
experimente en 30 años un aumento del
nivel del mar tan grande como el que
vimos durante todo el siglo pasado
el aumento de los niveles de los océanos
producidos en gran medida por el
derretimiento de los polos a causa del
cambio climático podría empeorar si no
se reducen los gases efecto invernadero